here we go ooh oh oh I do not like the
way that smells smells like a raccoon
threw up in a bag for the dirty diapers
hey what is going on you two
no case y'all haven't noticed I'm a man
somewhat and growing up I usually here
to shake a lot hell hath no fury like a
leg up let a [ __ ] torn that's not it
but something about would you piss off a
woman you better run the [ __ ] away and
this week's article sent by Jen's doin
nice the lady says a dude's car and gas
pump on fire after she asked him for a
cigarette excuse me sir do you have
cigarette not for you ugly [ __ ] fly
away that's cool that's cool
okay I can see all these muddies [ __ ]
I'm going to let this [ __ ] on fire holy
[ __ ] this is too real that is my
interpretation of what happened which
obviously means it's a hundred percent
true not just to put my two cents out
there in my lifetime I have run into my
share of crazy omens and in general you
are a guy and your data Dubrow chances
are you have to and if you haven't yet
well lucky you you [ __ ] [ __ ] sack
either that or you're watching this
video right now that crazy [ __ ] is
right next to you but in that case dude
I just picked you all nervous defending
us baby on the water [ __ ] you don't
worry brain you ever hear a guy say I
love you I'm a perpetual fear huh sounds
like you slip an ice cube of his
butthole [ __ ] what yeah but to be honest
with you have the time I saw a crazy
woman it was because a guy did something
to unlock the crazy within everybody got
a little crazy used me a little
something just to you know push you
right on over the edge Latia for me in
this video whether she's crazy or she's
not and I can't really justify the
action one has to wonder if she is
perfectly saying what the [ __ ] that guy
say to her because I'm not loud it could
have just been no I don't have cigarette
but on the other hand he could have said
no [ __ ] your [ __ ] look like pastrami
if you notice in the video after the
lady did it she almost looked surprised
that the [ __ ] actually caught on fire
[ __ ] what you think was gonna happen
when you put it open flame take gasoline
well I thought oh just go [ __ ] your back
I'm gonna tell you something about my
life motto my life motto is to prevent
myself from getting my face stopped in
at all cost
and the reason I've done so well in
preventing this from happening is
because a
stays out of trouble and then be I stays
out of women's ways and let it be known
you know the two angers women on earth
are Korean Hispanic women I later won
Mexico she try to get me into a fight
every four days [ __ ] no you crazy look
at this I'm soft are you just going to
let him stop for me like me you're gonna
tattoo on his face I can't do much and
any guy out there if you ever dated a
Korean girl and you somehow cheated on
her and you survived how the [ __ ] you do
it I have a theory that all Korean women
when angered have the strength of a
thousand baby rhinos I don't know what
it is about women in the Korean culture
for just curious but even Godzilla be
like [ __ ] it I mean you know what the
scariest thing though is when a girl is
mad at you and she doesn't say [ __ ]
because if they are not outwardly
emotive you already know you're about to
get [ __ ] up or there it did some [ __ ]
to you baby I cheated on you it's okay I
love you forever
what you got that job my ballsack when
did you snatch those and in general and
in general that [ __ ] minute before
but in Jenna fo in Jenna fo sounds okay
Oh funny